you
all right so let's let's sneak in an
hourly bullet arena
Mac oo6
don't drop your queen
[Music]
so far so good keep it up here okay
let's get rid of that light square
bishop let's keep this bishop opposite
there's hang out this square covered
take out e for drop back here keep him
around but I take away to see five
square one rook trade
you get their Bishop on c5 I'm lucky I
didn't just drop a piece I get into c5
in that night think he's going to be too
strong I am worse here timewise and
position-wise
oh they did that I draw
okay okay Pollux in there I see let's do
it
let's do it
see five go fishing
feels like they're making instant moves
or something or something
giving me the door
a bishop like that huh
okay
what's the plan man take there no
winning a Pawnee
all right I got a check and I'm up upon
flight square get one more trade in back
rank mate back rank mate aroni we got
385 so far page 2 just got bumped to I
see Tom Sawyer in there Chex Mix who
else
son Goku Bananarama 3000
fried liver is in first okay banana
banana Rama 3000
I like that in okay you're going to sack
here and have fun with the fork maybe
then the think tank okay so much for
that
and really I thinking this one through
thirty-six seconds what's going on here
thirty seconds five moves in
okay this is almost certainly a time
when almost okay tough pin to get out of
h3 I take and then take here when upon
night takes in the rook exercise just
winning stuff take someone down before I
take the rook or not maybe I could just
me
they just resigned back determine all
right front page I got five first is a
nine plenty of flawless players let's
try some g3 base setup
are you going to I thought they're going
to go queen c8 threatening a fork they
went too fast let's take the dark sir
they're not taking that pawn back may
not get them back now pins now still in
the pin skewers you got a trade Queen
the rook is hit
they did not move they not recapturing
strayed stuff yeah
they resign they're moving too fast
hi per bullet speed
all right
romantic chess and Tom Sawyer okay
romantic chess on board a sneaky pawn
attack let's let's open stuff up I'll
pitch this pawn no they don't want them
it's probably a good idea
okay I'm going to kick this night away
no hang on take that pawn oh I had a
mate in one
hmmm I had a mate
opportunity piling up on the pin night
ah man that just would have been a quick
kill
we got pins man pins he's defended
something's happening there pins the pin
variation
he's still going down f3
so check
which one you want mop a full rook let
stayin the night
tame the night get rid of the night he's
gone this could have been such a quick
win and that smothered mate
and okay that was a quick one over there
on the queenside their pond and bishops
coordinated well well the bishop and
pons all right let's try efore for once
ancient alien scotch now let's go gambit
mode for once okay challenge this guy
he's in my house
my house now I'm ready to win upon maybe
I should have captured the other way
then ready to win upon there a challenge
with f6 now now I get F for a fool
okay I'll keep this guy around the
Knights going to try to reposition to
get here but I should be able to open
stuff up let's go here b5
let's take once get a knock on b7 it's
tough to get the night here
yeah but let's try this then here oh
they could stop that pond
I didn't realize good night I could win
this can they stop this fun
this fun I got a lot of bonds here
plenty of time pushing through
let's make back to Turman 21 1917 kind
first is flawless
okay let's throw the H bond Adam
goes harass the bishop variation shoo
let's not taking it
let's take them now forks forks they're
flying
ona is flying duck okay I'm not trying
to take the night actually
I got this here and then I'm turning the
bishop in Knight now that they're
connected that's a pretty sneaky move
Wow good spot
that was a really quick find really
quick here flying
let's return g4 that's not working add
enough on that got this covered my night
is super to super night back ranked
mates let's be careful not give up the
file too fast too fast got this covered
now we're cooking this is a killer
bishop
where's the mate mate
they resigned back to tournament Wow
that was a really I'm surprised at how
fast they found a way to I don't know
that little check to defend the bishop
was a queen a six hit hit me with the
check and defended to e6 Bishop thought
I was going to win a piece all right you
got the win shut up and focus on this
game
you've lost many games thinking about
the previous the previous game alright
need to save this guy now what you can't
take back with the pawn
we're going to go queenside yeah let's
get rid of this night he's too good it's
in my house could take that pot if they
go clean side there's a pen I get map on
yep and control the only open file hang
on hang on hang on now that's two minor
pieces oh they had Queen here there was
a good follow up Queen here picked up my
rook keep it closed my dark square
Bishop is going to be an animal on c3
gotta play King here and I should be
able to just smash through right around
this point put the knight on a nice
central square let's just ignore that
stuff I could still take this is made on
the spot move the knight Queen here now
they have no shelter on the files making
one threat still making one threat no
save oh there's that move ah let's just
take like getting mate
how about check here here ring around
the rosy does that mate it is back
determined a little bit can
and about my back rank I wanted to do a
rook lift rook and then out rook what
squares that rook c6 to a six I wanted
to do okay 12-minute mark
tied for first I have fire my opponent
does not
ok-hee and sneaky okay
I can play Bishop to b5 they try Knight
there so now let's focus on there
without the King Knight so yeah now
there's some serious weaknesses start
with that and spending way too much time
I want to play Queenie - but then
there's this and takes I want my queen
over here
that's an odd move
okay so you're doing that to get this
pond back but okay I want to get a g3 I
want to get my my king heat whoa really
I think I'm there just in time super
defender yep I got a super defender I
just dropped their knight now they're
doing a push
a bit scary bit scary I just want to
take the rook I was ready to take the
rook next I just dropped on time just to
eliminate one of their attackers
ended up dropping our h-bombs two checks
neither of Assad caro-kann okay I am I
think better here already
okay I guess they're going to go Queen
side but I have a have play maybe this
was more to the point okay I'm fine with
blocking on a check I think I could do
this Queen takes Knight is interesting
ooh and I could take you and then take
here next amount of Queen
clean exchange is close to mate this is
a main threat
still have a mate threat idea where's
the king going let's continue with some
checks
I guess we'll take out that covered okay
Bishop here
let's take stuff get rid of this guy
where's the mate I had a skewer
also on the rook many ways to win pin
point be to take that pawn first they
resign back to tournament 33
3:29 2321 8 minutes remaining
1:55 in this on 56 crispy 99 let's try
g6 combined with c5 and we'll try this
gingy Indian okay see how they defend c3
you
okay Castle queenside
strike at c3 they're not doing anything
about that they avoid a queen exchange
they get here if they want oh I must
have been a mouse slip they just want to
take my queen I guess 37 2925 I don't
think that I played that right
a very interesting opening strategic
give up the bishop for night imbalance
to kill the structure take what the
Queen
I like well let's get the move back fast
let's get a flight Square stop Bishop to
g4 I'd love to see this push and now
this is a big issue bishop sneaking in
here is probably strong I like defending
this pawn now probably have a nice time
we push
let's support it I don't want to do it
too quick they're lining Bishop takes
pawn stuff up let's just kill the bishop
pressure on the nut a most mal slipped
clean here okay with that got upon this
night is killing their whole Queen side
I'm not taking the bishop if he goes
here
Oh house in check this bishops having a
very tough day the night still controls
these two pieces there's a son of
material they can never they can't they
cannot untangle I could just push all
these pawns up
okay
and big big trouble bonds are just
pushing through they're not stopping
keep going oh boy yep restrict the King
get the king all the way up plenty of
time now stalemates
to download time
that's see five square
five a monster Rage tilts we've played
many times
and I believe with this opening clean
exchange I like seeing that hunch my
LightSquared Bishop down now or not okay
giving me a pond
all righty I'm going to take him out put
my knight here I think this is a
reliable home knight on g4 let's try
this one
hmm insert this check first and then
okay didn't like
let's try this I'm in trouble I am in
trouble
oh boy I'm in very big trouble
oh they're on my rook I didn't see that
got the bishops can I do anything with
that they missed I'm on this
still on the bishops to check
I'm a time edge these bishops are
killers
Wow they're down on time whoo
tough tough tough tough opponent yeah I
mean those my two bishops there was
never
that's one of the positives with the
bishop hair
the enemy King cannot rely upon any one
color complex they're always putting his
post into question I'll save my dark
square Bishop from this manoeuvre as
well and okay get in a quick Bishop c2
they're going Queen side I'm going King
side and let's insist I don't want to
help strengthen their control over for
now I could just push through and now I
could maybe target stuff over here
let's sneak over
defending here now as soon as their
night moves my night jumps in I think
it's close to getting trapped if I went
clean here they're in a pin so my anyway
I could take here though take night
takes I'll give up the exchange my night
is pretty good I can break this down a
little bit with h4 let's do it let's
control that um okay and a lot of checks
let's just move over here they're okay
they're giving material back let's check
another check let's just do a a prevent
let's return
don't have much time yeah it's tough for
them to find moves now give a bunch of
checks now I'm probably just winning
objectively through down on time and
that's actually the last one I don't
even realize that flew by
Wow 178 and I'll 45:33 29-28 178 all
right let's see how the pages 2 3 4 5
all right
18 pages in all we're getting there I
like doing the hourly bold arenas over
the created ones there's a better
turnout
all righty to the 177 of you good games
all
you